alrededor de 800.000 estudiantes vuelven
hoy a las aulas tras haberlas dejado a
mediados de marzo sin embargo a lo largo
de este mes de septiembre van a ser más
de 8 millones de estudiantes
preuniversitarios los que vuelvan a
iniciar el curso y es que la entrada al
nuevo curso depende de cada comunidad
autónoma que son las que tienen las
competencias en materia de educación sin
embargo las distintas comunidades
convergen en ciertas medidas para evitar
la propagación del coronavirus dentro de
los centros educativos medidas que
consisten sobre todo en intensificar las
tareas de limpieza y desinfección pero
también en evitar que todos los alumnos
del mismo centro tengan contactos entre
ellos para ello se crean a grupos
burbuja que coinciden sobre todo con los
grupos clase para que por ejemplo si se
detecta un positivo en una aula en
concreta solo sean sus compañeros los
que tengan que ponerse en cuarentena
pero hemos podido hablar con algunos
profesores también que nos decían que
tienen que frente a esta situación el
currículum quede finalmente en un
segundo plano pero también los
profesores se quejan por ejemplo aquí en
la comunidad de madrid' de que el
gobierno regional no está cumpliendo con
las medidas que anunció para ello ya
está convocada una huelga
a finales de septiembre y es que hay que
tener en cuenta que este inicio del
nuevo curso coincide con un momento en
que se multiplican los casos positivos
en españa' en las últimas dos semanas
por ejemplo se han detectado cerca de
80.000 nuevos casos positivos pero hay
que tener en cuenta una cosa y es que
estas cifras no se pueden comparar con
las del inicio de la pandemia cuando
solamente tenían acceso a las pruebas de
cr las personas con sintomatología muy
grave ahora mismo se están haciendo
esfuerzos para rastrear incluso las
personas asintomáticas